Speaker 1: OK, let's continue speaking to
folks because people want to chat.
That's just the reality of what's going on
right now.
Let's go next to Chad from Florida.
Hey, David.
Hey, Chad, are you in Florida or Florida?
Speaker 3: Well, that depends on who you ask.
Speaker 1: OK, fair, OK, good.
Speaker 3: So my first question, or maybe
only when we can get to, is do you think the
left has sort of squandered this opportunity
to distance themselves from socialism, making
an issue of the embargoes or the authoritarian
or sorry, not socialism, communism, you know,
making an issue of the embargoes or the authoritarian
aspect of the government, as opposed to saying
we reject communism.
You know, Bernie Sanders isn't a communist.
He does.
He wants to implement, you know, some sort
of socialized health care.
We're not you know, he doesn't want to be
Cuba.
Speaker 1: No, I don't I don't think so.
Let me see.
How can I answer this in sort of the most
clear way, I've seen just about every prominent
Democrat say that they aren't supportive of
60 plus years of uninterrupted Castro family
rule in Cuba.
And at the same time, many of them, although
not all, have made it clear that the embargo
has been completely counterproductive.
And that's that's my position.
I don't know that there should be this expectation
of denouncing communism.
Every time you talk about Cuba just does it
doesn't really make sense to me.
I mean, when I talk about it, I just make
it clear I'm a progressive.
So I don't support authoritarian, autocratic
regimes run by what are effectively dictators
or at minimum authoritarian strongmen.
I make that clear because my audience sometimes
gets very confused about what my positions
are on these issues.
But I don't think it's reasonable to say every
time a Democrat talks about Cuba, they should
denounce communism.
That sounds weird to me.
OK, good answer.
My pleasure.
My pleasure